Y de hecho, elegí
un camino que no era exactamente lo que mis padres tenían en mente.
Cuando tenía 19 años, salí de la universidad,
abandoné, me expulsaron.
(Risas)
Y me tiré a la carretera como músico de trompa profesional,
que era mi sueño de toda la vida.
Toqué música de cámara en EE.UU. y Europa,
durante un par de años
con un gran guitarrista de jazz llamado Charlie Bird.
Y para el final de mis 20 años,
acabé siendo miembro de la Orquesta Sinfónica de Barcelona, en España.
Qué gran vida.
Y mis padres nunca se quejaron.
Ellos me apoyaron en todo el camino.
No era su sueño.
Lo usaron para informar a sus vecinos y amigos,
"Nuestro hijo, él se está tomando una década sabática".
(Risas)
Y...
había, sin embargo, una conversación incómoda sobre mi estilo de vida
de la que quiero hablarles.
Yo tenía 27 años y fui a mi casa desde Barcelona,
fui a visitar a mis padres para Navidad.
Y mientras cocinaba la cena con mi madre, solos en la cocina,
ella estaba tranquila, demasiado tranquila.
Algo andaba mal.
Y dije: "Mamá, ¿en qué estás pensando?"
Y ella dijo: "Tu padre y yo estamos muy preocupados por ti".
Y dije, "¿Qué?" Quiero decir, ¿qué podría ser?
Y ella dijo: "Quiero que seas completamente honesto conmigo:
¿has votado a los republicanos?"
(Risas)
La verdad es que
no estaba metido mucho en política, yo era solo músico de trompa.
Pero tuve una revelación,
y la habían detectado, y estaba causando cierta confusión.
Me había convertido en un entusiasta del capitalismo,
y quiero explicar por qué es así.
Se deriva del interés mío de toda la vida,
lo crean o no, la pobreza.
Cuando era un niño que crecía en Seattle,
recuerdo la primera vez que vi la pobreza real.
Éramos una familia de clase media baja, pero eso no es, claro está, pobreza real.
Eso no es ni de lejos.
La primera vez que vi la pobreza y la pobreza en la cara,
fue a los 6 o y 7 años, a principios de 1970.
Y fue como muchos de Uds., una especie de ejemplo prosaico, una trivialidad.
Era una foto en la revista National Geographic
de un niño de mi edad en el África Oriental,
y tenía moscas en la cara y el vientre hinchado.
Y no iba a sobrevivir, yo lo sabía y yo no podía hacer nada.
Algunos de Uds. recuerdan la imagen,
no exactamente esa imagen, sino una igual.
Esto introdujo en Occidente la pobreza extrema en todo el mundo.
Pues bien, esa visión me persiguió mientras crecía e iba a la escuela
y abandoné y retomé
y comenzó mi familia.
Y me preguntaba, ¿qué pasó con ese chico?
¿O con personas como ese niño en todo el mundo?
Y así empecé a estudiar, a pesar de no estar en la universidad,
en busca de la respuesta.
¿Qué sucedió a las personas más pobres del mundo?
¿Empeoraron? ¿Mejoraron?
Y encontré la respuesta que cambió mi vida,
que quiero compartir con Uds.
Miren,
la mayoría de los estadounidenses creen que la pobreza ha empeorado
porque desde que éramos niños, tuvimos esa visión.
Si preguntan a estadounidenses "¿Empeoró o mejoró la pobreza en el mundo?",
El 70 % dirá que la hambruna ha empeorado desde principios de 1970.
Pero esta es la verdad:
Tuve esta revelación que cambió mi forma de pensar.
Desde 1970 hasta hoy,
el porcentaje de la población mundial
que viven en niveles de hambruna,
que viven con un dólar al día o menos, obviamente, ajustado a la inflación,
ese porcentaje se ha reducido
en un 80 %.
Ha habido una disminución del 80 % en la peor pobreza del mundo
desde que era niño.
Y yo ni siquiera lo sabía.
Esto, amigos, es un milagro.
Eso es algo que debemos celebrar.
Es el mayor logro en combatir la pobreza en la historia de la humanidad,
y sucedió durante nuestras vidas.
(Aplausos)
Al enterarme de esto, me pregunté, ¿qué lo logró? ¿Qué lo hizo posible?
Porque si no se sabe por qué, no se puede volver a hacerlo.
Si se quiere replicar
y sacar a los siguientes dos mil millones de personas de la pobreza,
porque de eso estamos hablando: desde que era un niño,
a dos mil millones de, al final, nuestros hermanos y hermanas,
se han sacado de la pobreza.
Quiero sacar a los siguientes dos mil millones, por eso debo saber cómo.
Y fui en busca de respuestas.
E iba a por una respuesta política, porque no me importaba.
¿Y saben qué? Todavía no me importa.
Quería que la mejor respuesta de los economistas convencionales
izquierda, derecha y centro.
Y aquí está.
Estas son las razones.
Hay 5 razones para que 2000 millones de nuestros hermanos y hermanas
ya no estén en la pobreza desde su infancia.
Nº 1. La globalización.
Nº 2. El libre comercio.
Nº 3. Los derechos de propiedad.
Nº 4. El Estado de derecho.
Nº 5. El espíritu emprendedor.
Fue el sistema de libre empresa extendido por todo el mundo
tras el 1970 que logró eso.
Yo no soy ingenuo.
Sé que la libre empresa no es perfecta,
y sé que la libre empresa no es todo lo que necesitamos
para construir un mundo mejor.
Pero lo que es grande.
Y eso va más allá de la política.
Esto es lo que he aprendido. Esta es la epifanía.
El capitalismo no se basa solo en la acumulación.
En su mejor interpretación, se basa en la aspiración,
que es de lo que tantas personas hablan en este escenario,
es la aspiración que viene de los sueños
integrados en el sistema de libre empresa.
Y tenemos que compartirlo con más personas.
Ahora, quiero hablarles de una segunda epifanía
relacionada con la primera
que, creo, puede llevar progreso, no solo en todo el mundo,
sino también aquí en casa.
La mejor cita que he oído en mi vida
para resumir los pensamientos que acabo de explicar
acerca de sacar a la gente de la pobreza
es la siguiente:
"Los mercados libres crean más riqueza que cualquier sistema en la historia.
Ellos han sacado a miles de millones de la pobreza".
¿Quién lo dijo?
Suena a Milton Friedman o a Ronald Reagan.
Incorrecto.
Lo dijo el presidente Barack Obama.
¿Por qué me lo sé de memoria?
Porque me lo decía.
Loco.
Y dije: "Aleluya".
Pero más que eso, dije:
"Qué oportunidad".
¿Saben lo que yo pensaba?
Fue en un evento que hacíamos sobre el tema
en la Universidad de Georgetown, en mayo del 2015.
Y pensé, esta es la solución
que el mayor problema que enfrenta EE.UU. hoy. ¿Qué?
Es unirnos en torno a estas ideas,
tanto liberales, como conservadores,
para ayudar a las personas que más nos necesitan.
No es necesario decir a nadie en esta sala que estamos en una crisis,
en EE.UU. y muchos países de todo el mundo con la polarización política.
La crisis ha aumentado a niveles críticos.
Es desagradable. No está bien.
Había un artículo del año pasado
en las Actas de la Academia Nacional de Ciencias,
que es una de las revistas científicas más prestigiosas
publicada en Occidente.
Y fue un artículo en 2014
sobre la asimetría motivacional política.
¿Que es eso? Eso que los psicólogos llaman fenómeno
de asumir que su propia ideología se basa en el amor;
pero la ideología de sus oponentes se basa en el odio.
Es común en conflictos mundiales.
Pueden ver esto entre palestinos e israelíes, por ejemplo.
Lo que los autores de este artículo han descubierto es que
en EE.UU. hoy, la mayoría de los republicanos y los demócratas
sufren de asimetría motivacional política.
La mayoría de la gente en nuestro país políticamente activos creen
que están motivados por el amor, mientras que los otros están motivados por el odio.
Piénsenlo. Piénsenlo.
La mayoría de la gente por ahí dice:
"Sabe, mi ideología se basa en la benevolencia básica,
quiero ayudar a la gente,
pero los otros, están mal y en mi contra".
No se puede progresar como sociedad cuando se tiene este tipo de asimetría.
Es imposible.
¿Cómo lo resolvemos?
Bueno, en primer lugar, seamos honestos: hay diferencias.
No hay que minimizar las diferencias. Eso sería muy ingenuo.
Hay mucha buena investigación sobre esto.
Un veterano de TED es mi amigo Jonathan Haidt.
Él es profesor de psicología en la Universidad de Nueva York.
Él trabaja sobre ideología, valores y moral de la gente diferente
para ver en qué se diferencian.
Y ha demostrado, por ejemplo, que los conservadores y liberales
tener un énfasis muy diferente en lo que piensan que es importante.
Por ejemplo, Jon Haidt ha demostrado
que a los liberales les preocupa la pobreza
un 59 % más que la libertad económica.
Y a los conservadores les preocupa la libertad económica
un 28 % más que la pobreza.
Diferencias irreconciliables, ¿no?
Nunca vamos a unirnos. Incorrecto.
Esa es la diversidad en la que reside nuestra fuerza.
Recuerden lo que detuvo la pobreza.
Era la obsesión por la pobreza,
acompañado por la libertad económica
extendida por todo el mundo.
Nos necesitamos unos a otros, en otras palabras,
si queremos ayudar sacar a los siguientes 2000 millones de personas de la pobreza.
No hay otra manera.
Hmm.
¿Cómo vamos a conseguir eso?
Es algo difícil, ¿verdad?
Necesitamos un pensamiento innovador.
Mucho de esto está en esta etapa.
El emprendimiento social. Sí. Por supuesto. Fenomenal.
Necesitamos inversiones en el extranjero
de una manera sostenible, responsable, ética y moral. Sí. Sí.
Pero ¿saben lo que realmente necesitamos?
Necesitamos nuevos aires en la ideología flexible.
Necesitamos ser menos predecibles.
¿No es así?
¿Alguna vez sienten que su propia ideología ha empezado a ser predecible?
¿En cierta forma convencional?
¿Alguna vez sienten que siempre escuchan a personas que están de acuerdo con Uds.?
¿Por qué es tan peligroso?
Porque cuando hablamos en este país acerca de la economía,
de la derecha, de los conservadores,
uno siempre habla de impuestos y regulaciones y del gran gobierno.
Y desde la izquierda liberal cuando hablan de economía,
siempre es sobre la desigualdad de ingresos.
¿Cierto? Ahora bien, son cosas importantes,
muy importante para mí, realmente importante para Uds.
Pero cuando se trata de sacar a la gente de la hambruna
que muere y nos necesita hoy, esas cosas son las distracciones.
Tenemos que unirnos en torno a las mejores maneras
de mitigar la pobreza usando las mejores herramientas a nuestra disposición,
y solo se logra cuando los conservadores reconocen que necesitan liberales
y su obsesión por la pobreza,
y los liberales a los conservadores y su obsesión por el libre mercado.
Esa es la diversidad en la que radica la fuerza futuro de este país,
si optamos por aprovecharlo.
Entonces, ¿cómo vamos a hacerlo? ¿Cómo vamos a hacerlo juntos?
Tengo que tener elementos de acción, no solo para Uds., sino para mí.
Nº1. Punto de acción nº 1:
recuerden, no es lo suficientemente bueno tolerar a las personas en desacuerdo.
No es lo suficientemente bueno.
Hay que recordar que necesitamos personas que no estén de acuerdo con nosotros,
porque hay personas que necesitan de todos nosotros
que aún están a la espera de estas herramientas.
¿Y ahora qué hacer? ¿Cómo se va a llevar a cabo eso?
¿Dónde empieza esto? Se inicia aquí.
Todos en esta sala estamos bendecidos.
Estamos bendecidos por la gente que nos escucha.
Estamos bendecidos con prosperidad. Estamos bendecidos con el liderazgo.
Cuando la gente nos oiga, hablando de ideología impredecible,
entonces tal vez la gente escuche.
Ese progreso se iniciará en ese punto.
Ese es el Nº 1. Nº 2.
Nº 2. Les pido y yo me pido
ser la persona que hace difusas las fronteras
que es ambigua, que es difícil de clasificar.
Si Ud. es conservador,
sea el conservador que siempre habla de la pobreza
con la obligación moral de ser un guerrero para los pobres.
Y si Ud. es liberal, sea el liberal que siempre hable
de lo bueno de los mercados libres para resolver nuestros problemas
si se usan responsablemente.
Si lo hacemos, tenemos dos cosas.
Nº1. Tenemos que empezar a trabajar para los siguientes 2000 millones
y llegar a la solución que hemos visto en el pasado
y tenemos que enfocarnos más en el futuro. Es así.
Y lo segundo es que solo así podríamos ser capaces
de llevar la guerra santa espantosa de la ideología que sufrimos en este país
y convertirla en un concurso de ideas
basado en la solidaridad y el respeto mutuo.
Y entonces tal vez, solo tal vez,
todos nos daremos cuenta de que nuestras grandes diferencias
no son realmente tan grandes después de todo.
Gracias.
(Aplausos)